قال صحيفه ريتس ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يبقي
الاسرى اغلب الوقت معصوبي الاعين ومكبل
اليدين اريتس اضافت ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يحتجز مئات الاسرى الذين اعتقلهم من غزه
في معسكر للجيش في النقب قرب بئر السبع
وقالت الصحيفه ان عددا من الاسرى الذين
اعتقلهم الجيش الاسرائيلي من داخل غزه
توفوا في معسكر اعتقال في النقب والجيش
يقول انه سيفحص
الاسباب
عن جديد الوضع من غلاف غزه مراسله الجزيره
نجوان سمر زنجان ماذا عن الجديد وما
قراناه قبل قليل فيما يتعلق بمن يتم
ترحيلهم الى صحراء النقب ويتم التعامل
معهم في هذه الظروف وبعضهم قد توفي والجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول بانه قد فتح تحقيقا في
هذه
المساله نعم هذا تحقيق في غايه الاهميه
لصحيفه هارت عن المعتقلين من غزه كما
نشاهد طيله الوقت هناك اعتقالات ينفذها
الجيش الاسرائيلي في صفوف
الفلسطينيين من داخل مدينه غزه وحتى هذه
اللحظه لم يصدر هو بيانات رسميه واضحه عن
عدد المعتقلين عن مصيرهم عن اي مكان يقوم
باقتياد لكن هذا اليوم تنشر صحيفه قارت
بان المئات منهم يعتقلون ويتم اقتيادهم
الى مركز اعتقال في احد معسكرات تابعه
للجيش الاسرائيلي في صحراء النقب بالقرب
من مدينه بئر السبع وهناك يبقيهم غالبيه
ال الوقت معصوبي الاعين ومكبل اليدين في
ظروف صعبه للغايه بالاضافه الى ابقاء
الاضاءه طيله ساعات الليل اض ايضا وهي
مشتعله اي انه لا يسمح لهم حتى بالنوم
بحسب هذا التقرير لصحيفه
هارت توفي عمليا استشهد عدد من هؤلاء
الاسرى لا يوجد عدد واضح لعدد ال الشهداء
من بين الاسرى الفلسطينيين من مدينه غزه
او من قطاع غزه منذ بدء هذه الح الحرب لكن
هذا ايضا معطى خطير جدا وعندما توجهت صحي
فها ارتس للناطق العسكري الاسرائيلي قال
بانهم من مخربين وفقا لوصفه من حركه حماس
وانه سيقوم بالتحقيق في ملابسات استشهادهم
او وفاتهم هذا بالاضافه ايضا الى ان
الجيش صحيفه ارت تتحدث عن ان فقط 10% الى
15 بال ممن تم اعتقالهم حتى الان كشفت
التحقيقات معهم عن انهم قد يكون لهم علاقه
بحركه حماس هذا وفقا لتحقيقات صحيفه هارس
بمعنى ان الغالبيه العظمى ممن يتم
اعتقالهم لا علاقه لهم بحماس وفقا لما
يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي عندما يتم اعتقالهم
في طيله الوقت يتم ربطهم بكتائب القسام
وبعمليات مقاومه
و بشكل عام بحركه حماس لكن صحيفه ارس تقول
انهم فقط ما بين 10 الى 15% فقط وفقا لهذا
المقال الذي كتبته وقالت ان فقط من بين
المئات تم عرض
71 فلسطينيا منهم او اسيرا منهم على
المحكمه على احد القضاه لا اكثر بالاضافه
الى ذلك هناك ايضا نساء معتقلات من غزه
وقد تم اقتيادهم اقتياده الى معسكر اخر
بالقرب من مدينه القدس المحتله يعرف
بمعسكر عنا تووت هذه المعطيات في بالغ
الاهميه عبد القادر يوم امس سمعنا رئيس
هيئه الاركان الاسرائيلي هيرتي هاليفي
خلال جوله تفقديه لقواته في داخل قطاع غزه
يتحدث عن انه تم اعتقال ما لا يقل عن 1000
من الفلسطينيين من داخل غزه و وفهم من
حديثه بان اغراض ذلك هي للتحقيق معهم
للمحاوله الوصول الى معلومات استخباراتيه
قد تقودهم الى معلومات تخدمهم بطبيعه
الحال خلال العمليات العسكريه في داخل غزه
يعني نتحدث عن 1000 معتقل من داخل غزه
وفقا لما قاله رئيس هيئه الاركان
الاسرائيلي لكنه لم يعطي معطيات واضحه
ومؤكده حول عدد المعتقلين هذا صوت ل قصف
مدفع جديد يطلق الان باتجاه المواقع
الشماليه نحن في مقابل المواقع الشماليه
المناطق الشماليه في داخل قطاع غزه على من
في مقابل تحديدا منطقه بيت حانون المتاخمه
للحدود
الشماليه اذا القصف متواصل عبد القادر
ايضا لو اردنا التحدث عن الاوضاع
الميدانيه القصف الاسرائيلي على مستويات
مختلفه سواء كان بريا او بحريا
وايضا القصف المدفعي متواصل طيله الوقت
على مناطق متفرقه في قطاع غزه نتحدث
تحديدا عن منطقه جباليا جباليا ايضا
المخيم وكذلك في منطقه شرق شمال شرق غزه
تحديدا حي الشجاعيه
والاحياء المحاذيه له سواء كان حي الزيتون
وحي وجحر الديك ايضا كنا قد رصدنا يوم امس
غارات عنيفه وقصف مدفعي متواصل يكاد لا
يتوقف على هذه المناطق بالاضافه الى
المحور الاساسي الذي يتحدث عنه الجيش
الاسرائيلي حاليا وهي منطقه خان يونس في
الجنوب وقد اعلن صباح هذا اليوم بانه خلال
ال 24 ساعه الاخيره استهدف وقصف جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ما لا يقل عن 150
هدفا داخل قطاع غزه